hey youtubers is charlie so yesterday
during my game of thrones trailer
breakdown as you to submit all of your
questions i picked 10 of them with one
bonus question i have to say though most
people were interested in talking about
cold hands and general story progression
into books four and five i also wanted
to remind you guys that in about two
weeks i'm going to start my game of
thrones season for countdown series so
there's any type of video that you want
me to see during that just let me know
in the comments be sure to subscribe if
you're finding me for the first time to
get all that stuff because it's gonna be
a lot of fun i'll be doing character
videos house histories anything else you
guys want to see but let's answer some
questions careful for potential spoilers
for season four if you don't want to
know anything i tried to answer
everything as best i could without being
too explicit but here we go question
number one Alice say asks any chance
we'll see mention of the next big thing
for House Targaryen honestly I don't
think that ten episodes is going to be
enough to get to what I think you're
talking about I assume you're talking
about the big you know dance with
dragons plot point it's a strong
possibility for season five though
depending on where they end season four
they're gonna be several big moments
this season but of all the moments you
know in the east I think they're gonna
be like two big Danny moments so I don't
think the thing that you're talking
about is going to happen this year
question number two logic on asks why is
it that whenever the dragons are shown
it's always drogon in the spotlight I
like the other two so there are actually
a couple reasons that you really only
see drove on most of the time first
drogon is more of a character in the
books you know he's tied specifically to
a few really big moments that'll
probably happen this season the other
dragons have their moments too but
drogon is like the lead singer of the
dragon jam band he is the biggest in the
baddest the other reason is just from a
cost perspective it's super expensive to
do special effects for the dragons
especially giant dragons so generally
speaking they try to show the dragons as
little as possible that's why you know
in that trailer you know when you see
drogon spread his wings they probably
spent a million dollars trying to do
that question number 3 star plat 7 asks
where will they end the season at I
think they'll end the season on Danny
just like they did on season three
logically the strong moment for them to
end on would be Danny and Rogan if you
want to know what that is and you don't
care about spoilers read dance with
dragons chapter 52 other potential
places they could in the season would be
with Jon Snow and dance with dragons in
either chapter 31
or chapter 69 those are really towards
the end of that book and there are
several battles and major conflicts all
over Westeros and in the East usually
each season ends right after a great
victory or a great defeat so you can
really pick any major battle up to about
halfway through dance with dragons for
them to end the season on question
number four Andruw Jones asks who is the
woman that we see being burned by
Melisandre and the night fire scene so a
lot of people are wondering if this is
brian and i don't think it's her i would
say that it's a wildling or someone from
Stannis's own ranks given her age she
doesn't look like Brienne Mel Sandra
usually burned something or someone of
significance to provide magical aid to
stand as his army before a battle it
looks like this is going to happen
before they sail away from Dragonstone
so obviously Brienne would not be there
question number five andalib nism asks
why do you think that aria included
Melisandre in her prayer Mel Sandra is
the one that took Gendry away so she is
on aria [ __ ] list remember Aria got up
in her face and confronted her about
taking again Maria way to be sacrificed
she even foretold a little bit of arias
future her very very stabby future
question number six Ariana Quiana asks
will Shay have the same destiny as she
does in the books there were a ton of
che questions so I will try and answer
all them in this answer yes Shay will
have more scenes but based on the way
they teased us with the trailer I think
it will all play out in the same way it
does in the books meaning that the end
result will be the same but Shay will
get a lot more story than she did in the
books part of the issue with the che
character in the books is that it's
really hard to understand why she does
what she does because she's almost a non
character she has very little time in
the story I think the show is gonna try
and fix that too kind of better explain
and make things clearer question number
7 Mohammed hazir asks does John find out
about Rob or bran he learns about the
red wedding because Ravens were sent out
he does not know what happened to brand
though pretty much everyone assumes that
brand was killed by fee on because they
swap bodies whenever Winterfell got
sacked so he does think that most of his
family is dead but he doesn't know
anything about his sister's right now I
think he assumes that they're both alive
question number 8 Colin khatri asks do
you think I should read the books will
it improve or lessen my experience of
watching the TV show yes you should
always read reading is good now reading
the books is a lot of fun though mostly
just because they're downright awesome
you don't have to read them to follow
the show though but if you like fantasy
stories then yes totally go for it if
you start now by the time you finish
wins the winner will probably be done
that's just a bit of a book reader joke
because it takes so long for each book
to come out just think of how long it's
gonna be before we see dream of spring
question number 9 the warmonger asks do
you think that the white Walker the end
of the trailer is cold hands so time to
address all the cold hands questions
this was the other big question that
everyone had in the comments no I do not
think that it's cold hands from Dance
with Dragons mostly because Colt hands
was not a white Walker and this person
looks just like a white Walker Colt
hands looked like a white which is a
reanimated corpse so he looked more like
a zombie he also wore a really deep hood
it's possible that what the show is
doing is giving the cold hands part in
the book to a regular white Walker they
do mix things around a lot on the show
but I don't think that we can call
whoever this is cold hands so I think
that it's just a random white Walker but
he might do the things that cold hands
does in the book story question number
10 Amy Morris asks do you think they'll
run out of material for season five and
have to create new plots that differ
from the books eventually yes but not
quite in the way you think and not quite
in that timeframe people ask george RR
martin and the showrunners this question
all the time I think that wins a winner
will be finished by the time we get
season 5 but because they have to write
all the stories six months ahead of time
what will probably happen is is george
RR martin will give them an idea for how
he wants the characters to develop in
some logical signposts for the plot and
the show we'll just do its own things
within those boundaries so by the time
we get to like say season six the show
will be way off book but it will loosely
resemble what george RR martin is doing
because it's probably gonna be like 20
19 before we see dream of spring and by
that time the show will probably be off
the air in interviews martin has also
said that he considers the cannon that
the show is creating to be separate from
his book canon and bonus question and
last one footy level for ever asks did
you come across the books or the TV show
first so I learned about the books in
2007 and then read all four because at
that time there were only four and then
waited to 2011 for Dance with Dragons so
I did wait a little while I do refer to
specific chapters that there's a
question I have about plot points though
but it's been a long time since a
bread-like the first couple books
ideally what I'd like to do those you
know before each season kind of reread
the books but I don't always have that
much time so thank you so much guys for
submitting all your questions there's a
lot of fun as always unless they release
a new trailer again next week or new
footage for me to do breakdown for my
next game of Thrones video will be my
top five characters from season three
and don't forget in about two weeks i'll
be starting my video countdown serious
so there's specific videos that you
really want to see in that just let me
know in the comments right now click
here for all my season 4 breakdowns and
click here from while walking dead
episode 10 review we finally found out
what happened to baby Judith and it was
so awesome thank you so much for
watching you guys I'll see you tonight
high fives